dix ans après la création du rmi le
gouvernement met en place la cmu la
couverture maladie universelle qui sera
une prestation de solidarité la loi doit
être voté au premier semestre de cette
année elle permettra l'accès gratuit aux
soins pour 6 millions de français
les mutuelles et les assurances seront
mises à contribution pour financer une
partie de cette mesure le détail avec
juliette beau soigner gratuitement les
plus démunis c'est l'objectif de la
couverture maladie universelle
la cmu la couverture de base reste la
sécurité sociale mais la grande
nouveauté le droit à une couverture
complémentaire gratuite elle aussi elle
sera prise en charge soit par une
mutuelle soit par une compagnie
d'assurance la cmu concernera 6 millions
de personnes pour en bénéficier il faut
gagner moins de 3500 francs avoir une
carte d'identité et pouvoir justifier
d'un domicile
concrètement plus besoin d'avancer de
l'argent pour une consultation pour des
médicaments ou même pour acheter une
paire de lunettes
cette cmu sera financée par l'aide
médicale gratuite déjà existantes
les mutuelles et assureurs seront mises
à contribution à hauteur d'un milliard
750 millions de francs
l'état lui rajoutera plus de 2 milliards
de francs au total
la cmu coûtera 9 milliards et l'entrée
en vigueur du projet de loi est prévu au
plus tard le 1er janvier de l'an 2000
d'actualité